you
hello hello is this president barroso
yummy yes hello my name is mercy Olson
i'm calling from nobelprize.org the
official website for the nobel prize
congratulations to the european union
for being awarded the 2012 Nobel Peace
Prize and what message do you think this
prize sends to the world I think the
most important matters this prior sends
to the world is that the European
project and European Union is something
we must cherish something very precious
not only for us in Europe but also for
the rest of the world because the
European Union is in fact the result of
a project for peace that brought
together nations emerging from the ruins
of the Second World War and it was your
opinion and that United them in peace
around the values of respect for human
dignity freedom democracy justice rule
of law and respect for human rights and
your opinion was able to do it through
supranational institutions representing
the common European interest so it is
indeed a unique project that is a source
of inspiration for many people around
the world that are precisely admiring
this project of peace and also the
values that are so important we are also
broaden your plane engine that we are
the world's largest provider of
development and humanitarian assistance
that we are at the forefront of global
efforts to protect our planet and to
promote global public goods so I think
it is indeed a great honor for European
Union for all its 500 million citizens
for all the member states for European
institutions and it is a justified
recognition for this unique project that
has brought peace to our continent and
there is a source of inspiration for
citizens all over the world thank you
and one more question who will you send
to Oslo to represent the European Union
to receive the prayers yes I think was
not yet scherzo decide and we just
received in you yes yes I'm sure and
and how do you think this prize will
affect the financial crisis the European
Union is currently undergoing I think
it's a message of hope and confidence in
fact in times where there are some
challenges in the European Union and so
the fact that Nobel Peace Prize
Committee and indeed the international
community I think we can say the
international community shows this
narration and recognition for the
European Union it is also a methods of
confidence and encouragement for the
important decisions that we are taking
to overcome all the difficulties that we
are facing today thank you so much for
your time thank you very much
congratulations thank you for your room